so I watched all eight episodes of the
series I feel like I learned I feel like
I learned yeah I spent the weekend
watching I feel like I learned a lot
about you and I'm riddled with Envy at
some of the cool you got to
do all right I'm just being completely
honest but listen before we get into the
series I like throwing a few curves at
the beginning good you've done a lot of
cool stuff if someone has never seen
anything you've done before what is the
first thing you'd like them watching and
why road to Paloma it's a movie that I
co-wrote
directed and did with like six of my
friends and about an very important
topic on the Native American
reservations and I did it about 12 years
ago now yep yeah if you could get the
financing to make anything you want what
would you make and why oh well I feel
like I'm kind of in the middle of it
right now my dream was to make chief of
War I'm making it with apple and uh we
just finished the first season and so
we're in post right now so I'd say that
that's my dream to make this native
native Hawaiian tale um and we're doing
it yeah I'm really looking forward to it
and I know that you co-wrote a lot of
the episodes yeah yeah we created it
with my partner Thomas and um got to
direct with my friends and yeah directed
it too what's scarier uh spending all
day doing interviews or hosting SNL I
mean husting SNL will be the most
terrifying thing it's always the
scariest thing sure I I I could never do
it I I can't imagine what it's like when
you walk out from behind the thing and
you see the camera there and the
audience and you know the problem is I
need glasses too so I can't see it's
almost squinny but I can't see very well
and so I don't I can't get contacts in
to save my life um so it's really scary
the reading and also a little you know
slow so it's it's all gets very
nerve-wracking you know what I mean yeah
I I mean it sincerely I could never do
it I'm so impressed by anybody who can
um so one of the things about the show
jumping into the series you you you had
eight episodes and you obviously cover
you know guitars and um uh motorcycles
and your passion and and and photography
but was there anything that came close
to being on the show that you were
ultimately like I'm just going to focus
on these things yeah but I feel like I'd
want to save that if people liked it I
would do for season two so there's a lot
of stuff that I want to do I mean these
were the first ones where you know we
just we started with Discovery before
Discovery B in Warner Brothers and then
it's HBO Max and Max so we started a
long time ago was Discovery Discovery is
very heavy into motorcycles so that was
our original thing and like people
really L that and I was like all right
well that's what we're great at um and
then slowly introduce all the different
things like the knife making and the
jewelry making and and and and relating
that to the characters and my craft the
things that I love so it's like it's
it's really trying to you
know make them all intertwin together of
like what are the things that inspire me
or the things that I want to learn so um
there's tons of more things I want to do
I don't know if I want to spill those
yet because I
mean people love it so if they like it
then I can do another season and do more
totally so how did it work when you were
making the series obviously you were
filming everything at once um so how or
or am I wrong could you take the hard
part about doing this show is that you
want to sit with each one of these you
so you have to have the moment of
fruition right so wherever that moment
whether it's just me by myself then
we're going to go take it to the people
then we're going to talk about it and
then I got to disappear and then they
got to have to start putting it together
so have to send the crew in to start sh
shooting twice the building process then
I'll come back at the end of it and at
the end of it we're going to do the
reveal and then we either take that and
shoot the big event that we're doing or
you know how how we fit the the the last
part of it so I'm really there for the
beginning and the end and then we shoot
the middle of it because obviously it's
just that with the artist so it has to
the project could take two years to make
like to make a
29 electric car that's never happened on
a phantom is not going to you know I'm
flying in from Dubai just to be there
for the middle half so I mean I I do fly
in on the middle half of it too and
we're always trying to connect with all
these projects so it's very I'm trying
to juggle where where I'm at in the
world with whatever projects we're doing
so yeah um well one of the things I
could tell by maske wearing I'm like oh
that was like 2020 2021 you know what I
mean yeah I mean we started our first
push so we started in California we went
up to Northern California then we came
down we went all the way through Texas
down to like Louisiana and then straight
up and through North Carolina and then
went to uh where I started C season 2 so
we ended up in Canada and then that's
when so we did that big sweep through
and then after Co so one of the things
that I thought was really cool and I
didn't know about you uh going into this
series is how you've worked with your
friends and people that you really
admire to create these one-of-a-kind
items for your characters in Fast and
see in in in the new Apple
Series yeah exactly so can you sort of
take me through what is it like on set
are you telling the showrunner or the
director hey I have some friends I want
to create this how does it actually work
with the production yeah I um generally
you know even on Frontier I was
hired and uh I my partner Blaine hon who
I made Mele with he he did a lot of he
does a lot of different clothes and
stuff like that so I have him build my
own pieces but also he works with the
costume designer so the costume designer
would come in I just wanted him to age
certain things so the hero pieces were
aged and like even on Aquaman you know
Michael was a costume designer he he he
actually came to me he was like well
Aquaman's not going to wear polos and
you know suits so I mean like I want him
to look like what you do and I wanted
him to look like slash and I wanted him
to carry all the things of him going
from Village to Village to different
places around the world so he had
knickknacks and things that were special
that people would give him when he saved
things and did things so he had very
much he wore everything on him uh that
was like had memory and then he would
have very military things he's always
constantly traveling around the world so
whenever I build a character and so blae
helped me with those and so generally I
have someone who helps me and I go to
production and I ask for that and I and
I also just do it myself and I pay for
it and I show up and if they beat what I
made then they win if they don't beat
what I made then they don't win and then
you have to like I'm going to go invest
into my craft and I think this is what
it should be if you show up something
better where like Trish Somerville on C
I showed up for first season of c and I
didn't bring a thing she laid it
out second season I did a lot of my
stuff where I wanted to look a certain
way and I completely was like I want it
to be this and do this costume designer
made it I came with the props I go like
this is what I would like this is what I
would like and so you kind of just
go I think after over time they really
enjoy when you come with that much
passion um because when I did Fast At
first she was like and then we are now
very tight and because I just come with
like I want to play this character this
way I want him to look this way I want
to feel this way so everything uh is for
a reason and it's all for the better of
of of of the movie so I just think it's
a it's a little you pull back the
curtain to see this is what I'm obsessed
with I I wanted to bring this in here I
made these knives I was there when we
made them and and shoot it sure I will
say you were my favorite part of fast 10
your the way your character looked and
your the way you played the role uh
fantastic well I just wanted him to be
in pastels that was my first thing I was
inspired by a little necklace it was all
in pastels I wanted to be something
that's you can get close to and go like
oh that's not that harm harmful and the
closer you get I actually put contacts
in because I wanted to and you see those
black eyes you just said I have greenish
hazel eyes and when you put those dark
eyes in you're like o I got too close
and by that time it was too late and he
just used knives and he was dangerous
one of the things that I would imagine
the coolest part of your life must be
being able to cold call someone you're a
fan of and be like hey I'm Jason mimoa
I'm a huge fan of your work I want to
learn how you do your stuff can I come
by you know like who are some of the
people or like who is someone that you
still can't believe you were able to do
that with and who you got to learn from
let
Claypool Prim I grew up with Primus he's
hands down the greatest base players of
all time
uh calls me we talk all the time Todd
heido I mean he's my eyes I I I love
everything that he does Julian
Schnabel uh you know he's my him and
like Denny are my my top like those are
the people that signed my DGA when I
became a director I was like that's
that's ultimate I got Denny Denny and
Julian
slash yeah skateboarder Eric Ellington
like there my friends like there just
people that I'm like they're my friends
now and but still I'm constantly
inspired by them and they're wonderful
and they keep
pushing it's wonderful man yeah all I've
heard about the Dune sequel is that it
is phenomenal and that is no surprise
because Deni is a genius he is all that
bag of chips man he's amazing 100% so
something I was very curious about you
recreated these um classic guitars like
Slash's guitar from like the 80s right
so I'm foru sidan Appetite for
Destruction it's that was instruction
guitar so my question is and and even
like the 59 or the 60 Fender I forget
the um Pearly Gates guitar yes um so
what I'm curious about is when you re
when they recreated the guitar at
Fender can you act do does it actually
sound or wherever it was done I'm sorry
um does it actually sound like the
original or with the modern electronics
and modern wood does it have like a
different sound I mean that's something
for them but they use it on stage and so
when slash uses it he loves it and what
those Artisans are putting in the thing
is you can never you can never duplicate
that feel and that time and all that
energy put into that wood but over time
like you can get as close as you can get
to it these guys are going to do so um
but as far as getting the uh what they
can do with technology getting those PFS
and getting the uh the pickups as close
as they can they can really do that now
but having that historic of what was in
50 I mean you can never have the real
thing they were all individually
different and that's what gave them like
that's why they're the holy Grails but
these guitars that we made are so good
that slash and Billy take them on the
road so they're definitely the the best
you can get and it's cool because we
made that for them and then we made one
for charity so now we're going to go and
auction off when people get to see the
show let that resonate with people and
then we're going to start the auctions
yeah I'm I'm really I think it's really
cool what you're going to be doing for
Charities and uh uh if I had the money
say if I yeah maybe they maybe no one
watches the show and maybe they're gon
to go for
nothing I'm pretty confident it's going
to be uh out of my budget and that's
okay because I want these Charities to
make money so that that's totally fine
where uh are the 636s right now they're
all kind of split up right now they're
all kind of split up all over the world
because I've been down in New Zealand so
a lot of stuff's with me um where I
wanted to be so riding down there sure
I'm almost out of time and I want to ask
you this one of the things that I think
is great is that you uh want to use play
and and and share these vintage amazing
items and and you know these old
motorcycles and these guitars but there
um um there is the aspect of you want to
preserve also history so what do you
actually have that is actually so sacred
that you don't want to display it or
play it is there anything like that or
does everything like fair game to use
everything's Fair game to use as far
when it comes down to something like a
motorcycle or a guitar but it's the
things that are like sacred to me are
like things that my kids made things
that are like really personal things
that are like Irreplaceable um not that
guitars aren't but like the things that
I find really that I cherish aren't the
guitars and and motorcycles things like
that they're they're very
like they're very they would mean
nothing to you sure no I I totally get
it so basically like if you came across
a oneof one motorcycle it's being RI
it's being ridden no matter what there's
there's there's I mean a one of one
motorcycle I don't have something like
that's a one of one motorcycle so I
haven't had a haven't had to deal with
that um but if it was a if it was a one
of a one I tell you what I would do I
would share with the world so I would
basically take that apart I would 3D
scan it and I would make it available
and I'm going to go shoot it and make
something amazing with it and then we
can put that one up and it should be in
a museum which it belongs to be and as
long as it work and it still works too I
wouldn't ride it but I'd ride those
other ones and I'd try to make it better
and we try to blow it up and make it
better and blow it up make it better and
that's how we how we progress so but I
would if I took a one one I'd share it
and so I'd probably try to replicate it
on that note I need to wrap I'm just
going to say congrats on the series and
I do hope it's a huge hit for you I'm
glad you enjoyed it thanks for watching
Eight
Episodes